شكرًا أجنبيًا لوجودك معنا اليوم ، دعني
أبدأ بطرح السؤال الأكثر وضوحًا
وكيف تشعر بوجودك هنا في
السينما بعد 18 شهرًا من الحجر الصحي
والضربة القاضية.
مرهقون لأنه لم
يتم استخدام أي منا ، فقد كنا جميعًا في منازلنا ،
حيث كنا نعقد اجتماعات التقريب ، حيث
كنا نشاهد الأشياء عبر الإنترنت
ونعود مع الناس يشعرنا بالروعة
والإرهاق أيضًا
في نفس الوقت ، لذلك
هناك مزيج
من التعب السعيد الذي أعتقد أن
فريق الفيلم بأكمله لديه ذلك
لجمهورنا لأولئك الذين لا يفهمون
ما هي وظيفتك بالضبط ، هل ستخبرنا بالضبط
ماذا تفعل على أساس يومي
كمدير للمهرجان لذلك أفعل
القليل من كل شيء في الواقع ،
البرنامج الذي يقود فريق البرمجة
هو دوري الأساسي ، لذا فأنا أعمل مع
أربعة مبرمجين داخليين ومن ثم
لدينا 25 مستشارًا للبرنامج يعملون
معنا ولكل منهم نوع من
مجال التخصص  قد تكون صورة مؤثرة للفنان
أو قد تكون تخصصًا إقليميًا
وهم حقًا
يقدمون خبرة كبيرة للبرنامج ، لذلك
هذا ما أفعله على مستوى البرنامج
ولكنني أيضًا في الطرف الآخر
أفكر في الأماكن التي نوفرها
سنستخدم ما إذا كانت الميزانية تعمل
كما تعرف ما هي الشراكات ،
لذلك هناك الكثير إنها مهمة كبيرة
جدًا ، فما هي المعايير التي تختار بناءً عليها
الأفلام من الشرق الأوسط ،
هل هناك
مربعات اختيار أه محددة  عليك أن تمر
بما نحاول القيام به مع كل قسم من
أقسام البرنامج هو تقديم مجموعة متنوعة
من الأصوات ، لذلك نحن نفكر في
أشياء مثل أصوات الذكور والإناث
ونفكر أيضًا في الجماهير ، لذلك نريد
أن يكون لدينا أفلام من النوع جنبًا إلى جنب
أفلام الفنانين جنبًا إلى جنب مع
الأفلام الشخصية الحميمة ، لذا فإن هذا
النوع من جلب الجماهير إلى
أنواع مختلفة من السينما أمر مهم
بالنسبة لنا ، كما أنه من المهم حقًا أن يكون
لدينا انتشار في البلدان ، لذا
صادف أن يكون لدينا هذا العام عدد كبير جدًا  نوع من
القصة اللبنانية التي تدور خلال
المهرجان وأعتقد أن
هذا مناسب هذا العام لدينا صندوق ذاكرة من جوانا
هاتشيت توماس وخليل
وهو انعكاس جميل حقًا
على اضطرار أم إلى مغادرة بيروت في الثمانينيات ،
ثم لدينا أيضًا شيء
مثل البحر  إلى الأمام ، والذي يدور حول
تجربة بيروت المعاصرة وفقدان مدينة
كانت هذه الشخصية المركزية في الفيلم
تعرفها ذات مرة ، لقد تحدثت مع الكثير من
صانعي
الأفلام الدوليين ، وقد وصل
بعضهم إلى مهرجان لندن السينمائي في
السنوات السابقة.  هذا
العام ، وهناك دائمًا هذا الشعور السائد
بين صانعي الأفلام العرب بأن
مهرجانات الأفلام الغربية يميلون إلى
اتباع نهج استشراقي عندما يتعلق الأمر
باختيار الأفلام ومعظم هذه
الأفلام دعنا نقول أن هذا هو ما يمكن أن
نطلق عليه الأفلام الإباحية البائسة.  أن تكون حول
شيء ما حول النضال حول الخسارة
حول الموت
وهو ما يصور صورة معينة
للعرب في
العالم ، كيف تتفاعل مع
أعتقد جيدًا
أن مثل هذه التعليقات لا أريد أن يكون الأمر كذلك
لأنني أعتقد أنه من المهم حقًا
مع كل قسم من البرنامج أن
نقدم مجموعة متنوعة ، أعني
شيئًا مثل الأزقة التي أعتقد أنها ليست
أه بالضرورة فيلمًا سياسيًا في
وبهذه الطريقة ، يكون الأمر نوعًا ما من الجمهور الذي يصور
فيلمًا أردنيًا
هذا العام ، أعني أن هناك المزيد من
الأفلام القوية التي تحتوي على نوع من المضمون السياسي ،
لكنني أعتقد أنه من المهم
وجود مجموعة متنوعة من الأفلام ،
هل تعتقد أن المشهد السياسي
في  يؤثر الشرق الأوسط
على الاختيارات ليس بالضرورة في
مهرجان لندن السينمائي ولكن في أي
مهرجان أوروبي ودولي آخر ، هل
هذا
عامل يمكن أن يكون لأنني أعتقد أن
مبرمجي المهرجانات يبحثون دائمًا عن الأفلام
التي يتردد صداها ونحن نعيش في
عالم مضطرب للغاية ولذا
أعتقد أن هذه هي الأفلام التي غالبًا ما
يستجيب لها المبرمجون أيضًا
لأنهم يشعرون أنهم يتعاملون مع
قضايا اجتماعية وسياسية ملحة
لذلك أعتقد أنك تعلم أننا نريد
أن يكون الاختيار متنوعًا بشكل لا يصدق
ليس فقط الأفلام السياسية على الرغم
من أنك تعرف بعض القضايا السياسية الملحة
التي يتم استكشافها ، فإنني أعني
مثالًا رائعًا لفيلم
يشبه كل شيء حتمًا له بعض
النصوص السياسية ولكن  غرضها الأساسي حقًا
هو قصة حب لا تصدق
هي قصة ليلى بوزيد عن الحب
والرغبة التي أخرجتني في الواقع
لقد رأيتها في كان هذا الصيف ، وقد
شعرت بالإغماء حقًا عندما رأيتها
إنها قصة رائعة عن الحب الأول
وهي  رائع للغاية ،
نحتاج إلى المزيد من الأفلام المماثلة في الشرق الأوسط
في ريشي ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك لقد
كنت منزلاً رائعًا بالنسبة لنا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك